freecoat Camp has teamed up with
Microsoft to bring you a new free
professional certification and course
the foundational c-sharp certification
the course is a text-based course not a
video course this professional
certification includes 35 hours of
text-based training and interactive
coding challenges all from Microsoft and
also an online certification exam by
free code camp by the end of this
process you'll have earned your very own
verified certification that you can add
to your resume LinkedIn or cve in this
video freeco Camp team member Gavin long
will preview the course along with
telling you everything you need to do to
take this free course and earn the
certification
I'm really excited to introduce you to
this new certification offered to you
through a collaboration between
Microsoft and free code camp
the certification is named foundational
c-sharp with Microsoft certification you
can earn this certificate online
free of charge
hi and welcome I'm Gavin long
I've been a software engineer for over
20 years and an instructor for over five
years
I run my own YouTube channel mostly
dedicated to providing an educational
resource to.net and c-sharp Developers
and those that aspire to become c-sharp
and net developers with a great
knowledge of the c-sharp programming
language you can create many diverse
types of applications on a diverse array
of devices and platforms
you can also create sophisticated games
and who knows even start your own
lucrative business but you are in a far
better position than when I was getting
started the qualifications that I earned
were rather expensive to acquire back
when I was an aspiring software engineer
you are in a position to acquire this
certificate that will ensure
that you have a foundational knowledge
of the c-sharp programming language
without spending a cent I'm going to
show you how to do this in this video
before we look at an overview of the
process on how to earn your certificate
let's briefly discuss the many
advantages of having a good knowledge of
c-sharp and Dot net according to many
reputable sources c-sharp is
consistently rated as one of the top
five most popular programming languages
I've personally witnessed and
experienced how.net which provides an
environment in which your c-sharp
applications run has evolved from being
a sophisticated ecosystem that runs on
Windows platforms to a diverse modular
agile environment that enables your
c-sharp code to run on a diverse array
of platforms
since the release of.net 5 at the end of
2020.net provides a unified platform
that enables your c-sharp applications
to run on Windows Mac OS Linux iOS
Android and many more platforms you can
create sophisticated games using game
engines like Unity where you are also
able to monetize your games with C
sharpen.net you can create desktop
applications web applications like for
example Spa applications that leverage
the Blazer framework or you can Leverage
The asp.net MVC framework or the asp.net
Razer Pages framework for creating web
applications
you can create iot incidental things
applications machine learning
applications AI can easily be integrated
into your c-sharp applications you can
create cross-platform mobile
applications using the.net Maui
framework you can create Cloud native
applications you can run your c-sharp
code within Docker containers you can
for example leverage the microservice
architecture to create globally
distributed applications in the cloud
so you are almost unlimited with regard
to the types of applications you are
able to create using.net and c-sharp and
your c-sharp code can run on a multitude
of diverse platforms you are able to
download and install the tools for
creating c-sharp applications like
the.net SDK software development kit and
visual studio code free of charge so you
are only limited by your imagination and
your knowledge
the means of production is in your hands
I'm proud to have had three of my
c-sharp and net courses published on the
free codecamp YouTube channel
when you are ready you can go through
the step-by-step process of creating a
web-based shopping cart application
using Blazer webassembly and net web API
by following the step-by-step
instructions provided in this course you
can follow the step-by-step instructions
to create a sales management application
that leverages Blazer server with
Microsoft identity integration in this
course I also show you how to leverage
the sync Fusion components to create
sophisticated uis
can take your c-sharp coding skills to
the next level by gaining an
understanding of the more advanced
features of the c-sharp programming
language by going through this Advanced
c-sharp course okay but before we leap
into any of these three courses let's
first understand the foundational
concepts of the seashell programming
language
the foundational c-sharp with Microsoft
certification is offered to you through
a collaboration between Microsoft and
free codecamp and provides you with a
highly accessible way to gain up-to-date
essential foundational knowledge of the
c-sharp programming language
once you have gained the relevant
foundational c-sharp knowledge by
traversing the comprehensive material
provided on the Microsoft learn platform
this qualifies you to take the
certification exam
you take the exam on the free codecamp
platform and once you've passed the exam
your certificate will be saved to your
free codecamp profile you will then be
able to share this fantastic achievement
publicly on the internet
you will not be charged at any point
during this process
so how does this work
you start on the front page of the free
codecamp platform select the
foundational c-sharp with Microsoft
certification item and simply follow the
instructions basically the process
involves traversing the relevant course
material provided to you on the
Microsoft learn platform with each step
you'll be guided to the relevant content
through instructions provided on the
free codecab platform
the course material is divided into six
main parts that must be completed
sequentially from one to six each part
is divided into modules that you must
complete sequentially until all of the
modules have been completed once you
have completed all of the modules for
one of the six parts you are awarded a
trophy which is denoted by a HTTP link
that allows you to share your
achievement publicly on the internet
once you have earned all six trophies
meaning you have appropriately traversed
all six parts of the relevant course
material
you will be able to write the
certification exam
once you have passed the exam you will
be awarded your certificate
so
how has your progress tracked across the
Microsoft learn platform and the free
codecamp platform
firstly you must be logged into both
platforms
upon completion of each module you will
need to complete a challenge on the free
codecamp platform this challenge is
denoted by a multiple choice question
that you need to answer correctly before
progressing to the next module
once you have completed all of the
modules for one of the six parts of the
course material your trophy must be
saved to your free codecamp profile
please note this is how the process of
saving your trophy which is denoted by
an appropriate HTTP link is currently
saved to your free codecam profile a
more sophisticated way of linking your
Microsoft learn progress to your free
codecamp profile is in the pipeline and
May in fact be released by the time you
start your journey toward earning your
certificate so this process may be
different to the one depicted in this
video but please don't worry
comprehensive instructions in this
regard will be provided on the free
codecamp platform
once you have saved all six trophies you
are then qualified to take the
certification exam
once you have passed the exam which is
made up of 80 multiple choice questions
you can then claim your certificate
which will be saved to your free
codecamp profile
you'll then be able to share your
certificate publicly on the internet
I actually took the exam myself and
recorded the process so stick around to
the end of the video to find out how I
did
so let's get started we'll start by
going through the units in part one
module one step by step and in detail
so before you start going through the
course material in order to qualify to
take the foundational c-sharp with
Microsoft developer certificate exam
you must be appropriately logged into
the free codecamp platform and the
Microsoft learn platform let's navigate
to this URL to access the free codecamp
platform
so in order to see a list of all the
free free code Camp certifications let's
press the button labeled get started
it's free
we are presented with a list of all of
free code camps free certifications so
let's find the list item labeled
foundational c-sharp with Microsoft
certification
and there it is so let's select this
item to get started on the path to
attaining the foundational c-sharp with
Microsoft developer certificate
it's really simple to follow the path to
attain this certification the key is to
follow the relevant instructions on the
free codecamp platform and the Microsoft
learn platform as you progress
so we first get started with this
process on the free codecamp platform
by the end of this course you will have
gained the practical skills and
knowledge needed to confidently leverage
c-sharp for building robust and scalable
applications
so in order to start the first part of
the course material which is entitled
write your first code using C sharp we
can click this option denoting the first
module in the list this first module is
entitled write your first c-sharp code
there are six modules that we need to
complete in order to earn a trophy for
the first part of the course material so
let's click this link denoting the first
module to get started
so we are presented with our first
challenge immediately on the free code
Camp platform but we need to go through
the relevant course material on the
Microsoft learn platform before we
address this challenge which is a
multiple choice question
so let's first read through the
instructions
write your first C sharp code this
challenge will be partially completed on
Microsoft's learn platform follow these
instructions to complete the challenge
go to this URL and complete all the
tasks of the write your first c-sharp
code module this is required to earn the
write your first code using c-sharp
trophy
when you are finished come back and
correctly answer the question below
so this link here denotes the location
of the relevant Microsoft learn material
that we need to appropriately Traverse
navigating to the URL denoted by this
link will load the course material for
the first module on the Microsoft learn
platform into your browser
I recommend using the relevant free
codecamp web page loaded in the first
tab of your browser and then the
relevant Microsoft learn web page loaded
in a tab to the immediate right of the
tab containing the relevant free
codecamp web page so if you are set up
appropriately you can click the link
here and this will automatically add a
new tab next to the tab containing the
free codecamp web page and load the
relevant Microsoft learn web page into
the new tab
you can of course simply add a new tab
manually and copy and paste the relevant
URL denoted by this link into the new
tabs address bar in order to load the
relevant Microsoft learn web page
just as long as you have the appropriate
free codecamp web page and the
appropriate Microsoft web page loaded
and tabs adjacent to one another you are
in a good position to progress of course
at this stage you should also be
appropriately logged into free codecamp
and Microsoft learn so let's Traverse
the content for part 1 module one
part one write your first code using C
sharp get started with c-sharp part one
module one write your first c-sharp code
get started by writing code examples to
learn the basics of the c-sharp syntax
learning objectives after you complete
this module you'll be able to write your
first lines of c-sharp code
use two different techniques to print a
message to a text console
diagnose errors when you type code
incorrectly identify different c-sharp
syntax elements like operators classes
and methods
you can see this module is made up of
seven units and here are the headings
for the seven units then make up this
module so let's press the start button
and progress through the units in this
module
you can see here at the top the unit
number we are on
the current unit if you like and the
total number of units contained in this
module
so we're on unit 1 and the total number
of units in this module is seven
and we could use these arrows to
navigate in a forward Direction Through
the units and we can also navigate
backwards through the relevant units but
we need to Traverse these units in
sequence one after the other let's go
into this in more detail so let's read
through the first unit which contains
content for introducing us to the module
entitled write your first c-sharp code
introduction
the c-sharp programming language allows
you to build many types of applications
like business applications to capture
analyze and process data Dynamic web
applications that can be accessed from a
web browser games both 2D and 3D
financial and scientific applications
cloud-based applications mobile
applications
but how do you begin to write an
application
applications are all made up of many
lines of code that work together to
achieve a task by far the best way to
learn how to code is to write code it's
encouraged that you write code along
with the exercises in this module and
the others in this learning path
writing code yourself in each exercise
and solving small code challenges will
accelerate your learning you'll also
begin learning small foundational
Concepts and build on them with
continual practice and exploration
in this module you will write your first
lines of c-sharp code use two different
techniques to print a message as output
diagnose errors when code isn't correct
identify different c-sharp syntax
elements like operators classes and
methods by the end of this module you'll
be able to write c-sharp code to print a
message to the standard output of a
console like the windows terminal
these lines of code will give you your
first look at the c-sharp syntax and
immediately provide invaluable insights
so to progress to the next unit in this
module we can press the continue button
here
exercise write your first code
in this first Hands-On exercise you'll
use C sharp to print a hallowed
programmer's phrase to the standard
output of a console you can see here is
where we can write and run our c-sharp
code so in this module we'll use this
basic Editor to write the code for the
relevant exercises when we follow the
first module in the subsequent part the
second part of the overall course
material we'll install Visual Studio
code and we'll run Visual Studio code
locally and we'll write the code for
subsequent exercises and challenges
using visual studio code when we follow
the first module in the second part of
the course material we'll also install
the.net SDK so that we can use this.net
SDK to build and run our code
for this module and the other modules in
this part of this exam preparation
course material if you like we'll use
this in browser editor so let's continue
write your first line of code
there's a long standard tradition among
software developers to print the phrase
hello world to the console output window
as you'll experience you can learn a lot
about programming and the c-sharp
programming language from this simple
exercise
enter code into the.net editor
the.net editor and output console
provide a great in-browser experience
that's perfect for this tutorial
approach
the.net editor is located on the right
hand side of this web page
the output console is below it
enter the code exactly as it appears
into the.net editor on the right you'll
see an explanation of how and why it
works soon but first you should
experience it running and ensure you
entered it correctly so to do that
you'll run your code so we could simply
copy the code to the in-browser.net
editor here and run our code but here we
are being advised to write out the code
ourselves rather than just copying and
pasting the relevant code into the.net
editor note you might be tempted to
select copy or run and Skip all the
keystrokes however there are benefits to
typing code yourself
entering the code yourself reinforces
memory and understanding that will help
you gain insights that you wouldn't get
otherwise
so let's type out the code ourselves in
the.net editor
great
run your first code press the green
button the Green Run button performs two
tasks it compiles your code into an
executable format that a computer can
understand
it runs your compiled application
and when written correctly will output
hello world
observe your results
in the output console observe the result
of your code you should get the
following output
excellent
what to do if you get an error message
writing c-sharp code is an exercise in
Precision if you type just one character
incorrectly you'll get an error message
in the output area when you run the code
for example if you were to incorrectly
enter a lowercase C in the word console
like so
you'd get the following error message
the first part one comma 1 indicates the
line and column where the error occurred
but what does this error message mean
c-sharp is a case-sensitive language
meaning that the c-sharp compiler
considers the words console with a
lowercase C and console with an
uppercase C
as different as the words cat and dog
sometimes the error message can be quite
misleading
you'll need to understand the true
reason why the error exists and that
comes through learning more about
c-sharp's syntax similarly if you use
single quotation marks to surround the
literal string hello world like so
you would get the following error
message again in line one character 19
points to the culprit
you can use the message as a clue as you
investigate the problem
but what does the error message mean
what exactly is a character literal
later you'll learn more about literals
of various data types including
character literals for now be careful
when you're entering code fortunately
errors are never permanent you merely
spot the error fix it and rerun your
code
if you got an error when you ran your
code take a moment to look at it closely
examine each character and make sure you
entered this line of code exactly
note the code editor is constantly
monitoring the code you write by
performing pre-compilation to find
potential errors
it will try to help you by adding red
squiggly lines underlining the code that
will produce an error common mistakes
new programmers make
entering lowercase letters instead of
the capitalize C and console or the
letters capital W or capital l in right
line entering a comma instead of a
period between console and right line
forgetting to use double quotation marks
or using single quotation marks to
surround the phrase hello world
for getting a semicolon at the end of
the command
each of these mistakes prevents your
code from compiling successfully
the code editor highlights
pre-compilation errors to help you
easily identify and correct mistakes as
you develop your code
you can think of it like a spell checker
that helps you fix grammar or spelling
errors in a document
assuming you were successful in the
previous steps let's continue display a
new message
in this task you'll comment out the
previous line of code then add new lines
of code in the.net Editor to print a new
message
modify the code you wrote so that it's
prefixed by a code comment using two
forward slashes
you can create a code comment by
prefixing a line of code with two
forward slashes this prefix instructs
the compiler to ignore all the
instructions on that line code comments
are helpful when you're not ready to
delete the code yet
but you want to ignore it for now you
can also use code comments to add
messages to yourself or others who may
later read the code reminding you of
what the code is doing
add new lines of code to match the
following code snippet
press the Green Run button again this
time you should get the following output
great
the difference between console.write and
console.writeline
the three new lines of code you added
demonstrated the difference between the
console.writeline and console.write
methods
to print an entire message to the output
console you used the first technique
console.writeline
at the end of the line it added a line
feed similar to how to create a new line
of text by pressing enter or return to
print to the output console but without
adding a new feed at the end you used
the second technique console.write
so the next call to console.write prints
another message to the same line
congratulations on writing your first
lines of code excellent
okay so we can now progress to the next
unit by pressing this continue button
learn how it works to understand how
your code works you need to step back
and think about what a programming
language is
consider how your code communicates
commands to the computer
what is a programming language
programming languages like c-sharp let
you write instructions that you want the
computer to carry out
each programming language has its own
syntax but after learning your first
programming language and attempting to
learn another one you'll quickly realize
that they all share many similar
Concepts a programming language's job is
to allow a human to express their intent
in a human readable and understandable
way the instructions you write in a
programming language are called source
code or just code software developers
write code at this point a developer can
update and change the code but the
computer can't understand the code the
code first must be compiled into a
format that the computer can understand
what is compilation
a special program called a compiler
converts your source code into a
different format that the computer's
Central Processing Unit CPU can execute
when you used the Green Run button in
the previous unit the code you wrote was
first compiled then executed
why does code need to be compiled
although most programming languages seem
cryptic at first they can be more easily
understood by humans than the computers
preferred language
the CPU understands instructions that
are expressed by turning thousands or
millions of tiny switches either on or
off
compilers Bridge these two worlds by
translating your human readable
instructions into a computer
understandable set of instructions
what is syntax the rules for writing
c-sharp code is called syntax just like
human languages have rules regarding
punctuation and sentence structure
computer programming languages also have
rules those rules Define the keywords
and operators of C sharp and how they
are put together to form programs
when you wrote code into the.net editor
you may have noticed subtle changes to
the color of different words and symbols
syntax highlighting is a helpful feature
that you'll begin to use to easily spot
mistakes in your code
that don't conform to the syntax rules
of C sharp
how did your code work let's focus on
the following line of code you wrote
console.writeline hello world
when you ran your code you saw the
message hello world was printed to the
output console when the phrase is
surrounded by double quotation marks in
your c-sharp code it's called a literal
string
in other words you literally wanted the
characters h e l l o and so on sent to
the output
the console part is called a class
classes own methods
or you could say the methods live inside
a class
to visit the method you must know which
class it's in for now think of a class
as a way to represent an object
in this case all of the methods that
operate on your output console are
defined inside the console class there's
also a DOT or period that separates the
class name console and the method name
right line the period is the member
access operator in other words the dot
is how you navigate from the class to
one of its methods the right line part
is called a method
you can always spot a method because it
has a set of parentheses after it each
method has one job the right line
method's job is to write a line of data
to the output console
the data that's printed is sent in
between the opening and closing
parentheses of an input parameter
some methods need input parameters While
others don't
but if you want to invoke a method you
must always use the parentheses after
the method's name the parentheses are
known as the method invocation operator
finally the semicolon is the end of
statement operator a statement is a
complete instruction in C sharp the
semicolon tells the compiler that you
finished entering the command
don't worry if all of these ideas and
terms don't make sense for now all you
need to remember is that if you want to
print a message to the output console
use console.writeline
your message here like this
capitalize console write and line use
the correct punctuation because it has a
special role in C sharp
if you make a mistake just spot it fix
it and rerun
so here we have a tip to advise us on
how to memorize the c-sharp syntax
create a cheat sheet for yourself until
you've memorized certain key commands
understand the flow of execution it's
important to understand the flow of
execution in other words your code
instructions were executed in order one
line at a time until there were no more
instructions to execute
some instructions will require the CPU
to wait before it can continue
other instructions can be used to change
the flow of execution
now let's test what we've learned
each module features a simple Challenge
and if you get stuck you'll be supplied
with a solution in the next unit you'll
get a chance to write some c-sharp code
on your own
right
so now we get the first knowledge check
so it's just a straightforward multiple
choice question
what is the difference between
console.write and console.writeline
is the answer
console.write prints the output on a new
line
console.writeline prints the output on a
new line or is the answer
console.writeline appends a new line
after the output
so we know the answer is item three
console.writeline appends a new line
after the output
but I want to demonstrate what happens
if we choose an incorrect answer so
let's select Option 1 which is clearly
Incorrect and press the check your
answers button
so we are presented with a dialog that
contains the message congratulations you
earned experience points for completing
the knowledge check on this dialog we
can either click the button labeled
continue or the button labeled review
answers just a reminder you should at
this point be logged in to Microsoft
learn with your Microsoft account so
that your progress is recorded as you
progress through the relevant course
material
at the end of each part of the course
material when I say part please don't
confuse this with a module each of the
six parts contains multiple modules
there are six parts overall so once you
have appropriately traversed all of the
modules contained in a particular part
you will earn a trophy which is denoted
by a URL link that must be appropriately
saved to your free codecam profile we'll
look at the details of how to do this at
the appropriate point in this video for
now please be aware that you must be
logged into Microsoft learn and free
codecamp so that your progress is
appropriately recorded this is so that
once you have gone through all the
course material your progress would have
been recorded which will enable you to
write the foundational c-sharp with
Microsoft certification exam on the free
codecamp platform
so let's choose to click the review
answers button here so that we can see
where we went wrong with our answer
choice I find it is often a good idea to
go over my answers after each knowledge
check to make sure that I've properly
understood the relevant course material
so let's press the review answers button
and Microsoft learn gives us feedback
clarifying why our choice was incorrect
Microsoft learn provides us with clear
reasons as to why the answer we chose is
incorrect and why the correct answer
should have been chosen so it is often a
good idea especially if you have chosen
an incorrect answer to review your
answers before progressing to the next
unit in the module so as to ensure that
you have gained the appropriate
knowledge before progressing great so
let's move on to the next unit by
clicking the continue button here
so here we are presented with a
challenge it is explained to us here
that in order to complete this challenge
we need to use a combination of both
console.write and console.writeline to
produce this output so please briefly
pause the video read through the
provided instructions regarding this
Challenge and attempt to write the code
to solve this challenge
then I'll show you my solution to the
challenge
okay so here's my solution to the
great I'm getting the correct output
let's review the solution provided by
Microsoft learn so we can press the
continue button to progress to the next
unit where we'll be able to review the
provided solution to the challenge okay
so the provided solution is slightly
different to the one that I came up with
but that's okay both Solutions are
correct
this code is just one possible solution
among many possible ways to achieve the
same result however you should have used
both the console.writeline and
console.write methods to produce the
desired result there is often more than
one correct way to solve a coding
challenge great
okay so we can now progress to the
penultimate unit in this module which is
a knowledge check unit which entails us
taking a multiple choice test to test
the knowledge we have just acquired
so let's click the continue button to
progress
and let's check our knowledge by taking
this multiple choice test so please read
through each multiple choice question
and with each question select one of the
provided options you think correctly
answers the question
let's check our answers excellent we
have definitely learned something
so
once the check your answers button is
pressed we are presented with a dialogue
saying congratulations you earned
experience points for completing the
knowledge check so because we are
appropriately logged into the Microsoft
learn platform our progress is
appropriately recorded
so this time all of our answers are
correct and we are happy that we have
comprehended all the relevant course
material so this time let's press the
continue button on the dialog in order
to progress to the next unit
so at this last unit we are presented
with a summary of what we have learned
by going through this module
we also have a button labeled unlock
achievement
it is of course important that before
you press this button that you read
through this summary
so after reading the summary if you
press this button we are presented with
a dialog that contains the message you
did it
so this means we have completed the
relevant module
and our progress has been recorded in
our Microsoft learn profiles so we can
now press the continue button here we
are presented with three learning paths
in this dialog we are going to continue
with the second option here write your
first code using C sharp get started
with C sharp part one
but we don't need to click this link
here in the context of the foundational
c-sharp with Microsoft certification we
must follow the instructions on the free
code Camp web page that should be loaded
in the browser window on the left tab of
our browsers
so after completing each module the next
step is to go back to the free codecamp
tab in your browser
and pass the challenge which is a
multiple choice question
so for clarity what I like to do after
completing a module is close down the
Microsoft learn tab before taking the
relevant free code Camp challenge
then when we are on the free codecamp
tab we can address the relevant
challenge so this multiple choice
question which is our challenge is
asking us what is the difference between
console.write and console.writeline
the possible answers are console.write
prints the output on a new line
console.writeline prints the output on a
new line and
console.writeline appends a new line
after the output so we know after
traversing and comprehending the
relevant course material in the first
module of the first part of this course
material that option three is clearly
the correct answer so let's select
option three and then click the check
your answer button
a dialog is then presented to us showing
us our progress through part one of the
course material so the next step is to
click the button labeled submit and go
to next challenge so let's do that
we are now presented with the next
challenge on free code camp
this challenge pertains to part 1 module
two and we have only at this stage
traversed the course material for part
one module one so this challenge
pertains to part one module two which is
entitled store and retrieve data using
literal and variable values in C sharp
let's read the instructions here
this challenge will be partially
completed on Microsoft learns platform
follow these instructions to complete
the challenge go to
referring to a particular link and
complete all the tasks for the store and
retrieve data using literal and variable
values in C sharp module this is
required to earn the write your first
code using c-sharp trophy
when you are finished come back and
correctly answer the question below
so we are being prompted to go through
the course material before we complete
The Challenge on this page on free
codecamp so let's open a new tab next to
our free codecamp Tab and make sure the
new tab is navigated to the URL denoted
by this link here
so I'll appropriately open that new tab
pointing to this appropriate location by
clicking this link
great
so we can now appropriately Traverse the
course material for part 1 module two
store and retrieve data using variable
values in C sharp
so in preparation for the foundational
c-sharp with Microsoft developer
certificate exam
you'll need to appropriately follow the
relevance instructions as you progress
through each unit in this module this
video is just an instructional guide and
overview so I won't go through this
module in the depth that I went through
for module one so I'm going to speed
through the units in module 2 to the
final unit
great
and then at the end of module 2 we
simply repeat the process of closing
down the Microsoft learn tab taking the
challenge on the free codecamp web page
loaded into the free codecam tab
and then load the next Microsoft learn
module in this case module 3 of part 1
into a tab next to the free codecamp tab
a link to the location of module 3 is
provided in the web page loaded on the
relevant free codecam tab in our
browsers we can then appropriately
Traverse the course material in module 3
there are six modules in part one so in
order to prevent this video from being a
35 hour video
I'm going to fast forward through all of
the remaining modules in this part right
till the end of module 6. module 6 is
entitled guided project calculate final
GPA
where we'll earn a trophy for completing
all the modules in part one of the
relevant course material
so we have now completed all of the
modules we are on the final unit of
module 6 of part one
we must now press the unlock achievement
button on this web page we are presented
with a dialog containing a message you
earned a trophy so we can now close down
the Microsoft learn Tab and take the
final challenge for part one on the free
codecamp tab like this
so let's answer the relevant multiple
choice question let's click the button
labeled submit and go to next challenge
so we have completed the course material
for part one I.E where we have traversed
all six modules contained in part one
and have comprehended the relevant
course material and we have completed
all of the free code Camp challenges
pertaining to all of the six modules in
part one so the next step is to copy the
link denoting the trophy that we have
earned for completing part one of the
course material and paste the link into
this text box labeled Microsoft link on
this free codecamp webpage we can then
click the button labeled I've completed
this challenge before we do this let's
read the instructions on the relevant
free codecamp web page trophy write your
first code using C sharp
so this is the title for part one of the
course material
now that you've completed all the write
your first code using c-sharp modules on
Microsoft learn platform submit the URL
to your trophy below follow these
instructions to find your trophy URL go
to and then there's a reference to a
specific URL
using a browser you are logged into
Microsoft with find the trophy for write
your first code using C sharp and click
the share icon next to it click the copy
URL button paste the URL into the input
below the URL should look similar to
this this trophy is required to qualify
to take the certification exam
great so let's follow these instructions
so first we must be appropriately logged
into Microsoft learn and free codecamp
we can click this link to locate our
trophy
and you can see here we have this panel
if you like write your first code using
C sharp
we can then click this button and click
this item from the drop down list to
copy the link that denotes our trophy to
our clipboards let's go back to the free
codecamp Tab and copy the contents of
our clipboards into the relevant text
box labeled Microsoft link
and then click the button labeled I've
completed this challenge
we are then presented with a dialog box
showing us our progress
we can then click the button labeled
submit and go to next challenge
we are presented with a page showing us
all the course parts and modules that we
need to appropriately Traverse before
writing the foundational c-sharp with
Microsoft developer certificate exam
so we must follow the same basic pattern
as we Traverse the course material for
part two create and run simple c-sharp
console applications
module 1 which is entitled install and
configure Visual Studio code
so we are on part 2 module one
and in this part we are going to install
Visual Studio code on our local machines
as well as the.net SDK basically this
module contains instructions for
installing Visual Studio code a great
tool that we can use for editing and
debugging our code on our local machines
this module also contains instructions
for installing the.net SDK SDK stands
for software development kit which is a
tool we can use to build and run our
code by typing relevant commands in the
terminal window within Visual Studio
code this module also contains material
that teaches us about Visual Studio code
and the.net SDK so basically you need to
progress through this module in much the
same way as we've progressed through
part 1 module one so we completed part 1
module one and we fast forwarded through
the other five modules to complete part
one and we are looking at part 2 module
1. you will of course need to properly
complete all the six modules in part one
before getting to this point but this
video is intended to provide you with
basic instructions in the interests of
time we are not comprehensively covering
all of the relevant course material in
this video you will of course need to
cover all the course material and
comprehend the relevant course material
in order to qualify to take the
certification exam on the free codecam
platform pass the exam and attain your
foundational c-sharp with Microsoft
developer certificate
so you must go through all of the
material in this module in order to
progress to the next module but in this
video I'm simply going to provide basic
instructions in my own words on how to
install Visual Studio code on your local
machines configure the c-sharp dev kit
extension for visual studio code and
install the.net SDK so let's start part
2 module 1.
I'm not going to read through all of the
reading material in this module but in
this part of the video I'll demonstrate
installing Visual Studio code and
the.net SDK
you will need to go through the material
in this module for a detailed
explanation of this process let's first
see what Microsoft learns says about
Visual Studio code here
Visual Studio code is a lightweight but
powerful source code editor that runs on
your desktop and is available for
Windows Mac OS and Linux
it comes with built-in support for
JavaScript typescript and node.js and
has a rich ecosystem of extensions for
other languages and runtimes such as C
plus c-sharp Java python PHP go and.net
right let's install Visual Studio code
firstly let's navigate to this URL in
our browsers where we can download the
appropriate version of Visual Studio
code to our local machines
we can then go through the installation
process which is fairly straightforward
this Microsoft learn module provides
comprehensive installation instructions
so let's navigate to this URL
and let's click this button to download
the appropriate version of Visual Studio
code
if you look at the items in this drop
down list you can see that you are able
to download a version of Visual Studio
code that is appropriate to your
operating system I'm running Windows 11.
so let's press the button to download
visual studio code
let's navigate to our downloads folder
and run the relevant install file by
double clicking on it
and it's a simple case of going through
the installation process by following
the instructions on the relevant dialog
once we have installed Visual Studio we
can fire it up and look at the relevant
parts of the interface a the activity
bar is the narrow vertical bar located
on the far left hand side of the window
the activity bar lets you switch between
views such as Explorer or extension and
gives you other context specific
indicators B
the sidebar contains views that provide
tools and resources the sidebar views
such as Explorer are very helpful when
you're working on a code project C the
editor is the area used to edit your
files you can open as many editors as
you like side by side vertically and
horizontally
d
the panel area is used to display
different panels below the editor region
for output or debug information errors
and warnings or an integrated Terminal E
the status bar is the horizontal bar
along the bottom of the window
that displays information about the
opened project and the files you edit
f
the main menu is the menu interface at
the top of the application window the
menu options enable you to save edit and
run your code and much more
as you become more proficient with
Visual Studio code you'll be working in
the screen areas described
to start out however the most important
areas for you to remember are the
activity bar the sidebar and the editor
the activity bar is where you select the
activity you want to perform the sidebar
displays tools and options and the
editor displays the information that you
edit usually your code
in unit 5 of this module we have
instructions for configuring Visual
Studio code extensions the extension
that we are going to install will help
us to develop edit and debug c-sharp
code and visual studio code
so one thing to note is that rather than
install this c-sharp extension there's a
more updated extension we should install
this updated extension the c-sharp dev
kit extension this extension Builds on
top of the great c-sharp language
capabilities provided by the c-sharp
extension and enhances your c-sharp
environment by adding a set of powerful
tools and utilities that integrate
natively with vs code to help c-sharp
developers write debug and maintain
their code faster and with fewer errors
some of this new tooling includes but is
not limited to c-sharp project and
solution management fire and integrated
solution Explorer
native testing environment to run
anti-bug tests using the test Explorer
Roslin powered language service for best
in-class c-sharp language features such
as code navigation refactoring semantic
awareness and more
AI assisted development
so let's install the c-sharp dev kit
extension like this
great
so we have now installed Visual Studio
code and installed the c-sharp dev kit
extension so that we can effectively
edit and debug our code
but we also need a tool that we can use
to build and run our c-sharp code so we
are going to use the.net SDK for this
purpose SDK stands for software
development kit the latest stable
release at the time of creating this
video of the.net SDK is version 7. so we
can download and install the.net SDK
from this URL like this
I'm not going to complete this
installation because I already have a
preview release of.net 8 installed which
is fine for running through the code
examples that I'd like to go through in
this video but please complete this
installation so that you have the
appropriate version of the latest stable
release of the.net SDK installed on your
local machine for going through the code
exercises guided projects and challenges
in this course material I recommend
installing the latest stable release of
the.net SDK which at the time of
creating this video is version 7. so
once you have installed the.net SDK you
can verify that you have installed
the.net SDK by typing.net dash dash
version like this add your command
prompt in the terminal window of Visual
Studio code like this
my output confirms that I have net 8
preview 6 installed
you are able to have multiple
versionsoft.net installed on your local
machines
you are able to see what versions you
have of.net installed on your machines
by running this command dot net dash
dash info
dotnet is a cross-platform open source
developer platform that can be used to
develop different types of applications
it includes the software languages and
code libraries used to develop.net
Applications you can write.net
applications in c-sharp F-sharp or
Visual Basic the.net runtime is the code
Library that's required to run your
c-sharp applications you may also see
the.net runtime referred to as the
common language runtime or CLR the.net
runtime isn't required to write your
code but it's required to actually run
your applications
the.net software developer kit SDK
includes a command line interface CLI
that can be accessed from Visual Studio
code's integrated terminal during this
training you use.net CLI commands to
create new console applications build
your project code and run your
applications for example the
following.net CRI command will create a
new console application in the specified
folder location
so in order to create a.net console
application you can type this command
dot net new console Dash o
dot forward slash C sharp project
forward slash test project
so let's create a very basic.net console
project that we can open in Visual
Studio code firstly create a directory
on your local machine I.E where you'd
like to store your c-sharp code files
for your c-sharp project
so I'm going to create a folder named
Dev in my C drive for this purpose
then open the directory you have just
created within Visual Studio code like
this
you'll notice that within the terminal
window your current directory is the one
that you have just opened within Visual
Studio code
so to create a.net console project you
can type this command within your
terminal window like this and press the
enter key so dot net
space new space console space Dash o
space dot forward slash C sharp projects
forward slash test project
so this command has created a c-sharp
projects folder and within the c-sharp
projects folder a folder named test
project notice that within the test
project folder we have a file named test
project that has a DOT CS Project
Extension this file denotes the console
project that we have just created
in the Explorer panel expand the c-sharp
projects folder you should see the test
project folder and two files a c-sharp
program file named program.cs
and a c-sharp project file named
testproject.cs project the CLI command
uses the folder name when it creates a
project named
testproject.cs project
the program.cs file is the file
containing your c-sharp code
in order to run the code for our c-sharp
project using the appropriate.net CLI
command
we need the test project directory to be
our current directory
this is because the dot CS project file
resides in the test project directory so
let's make test project our current
directory using the CD command
let's edit our code in the program.cs
file so that our application outputs
hello C sharp rather than hello world
before we build or run our code we must
first save our changes so let's do that
through the file menu like this
before we run our code let's first run
the.net build command to see if our code
compiles
great build succeeded
then to run our code let's type the.net
run command and press the enter key
excellent and that is an expected result
hello c-sharp is printed to the terminal
window our application has run
successfully
module 3 of part two okay
so let's skip to module 3 of part two so
we are still on the same part part two
create and run simple c-sharp console
applications get started with C sharp
part two
we are skipping to module 3 add decision
logic to your code using IF else and
else if statements in C sharp
you will of course need to properly
Traverse all of the preceding course
material
before you get to this point but this
part of the video is just to give you an
idea of some of the Practical code
examples that you'll create at various
points as you go through the relevant
course material
let's skip to unit 4 of this module and
look at an overview of this code
challenge challenge improve renewal rate
of subscriptions
you've been asked to add a feature to
your company's software the feature is
intended to improve the renewal rate of
subscriptions to the software your task
is to display a renewal message when a
user logs into the software system and
is notified their subscription will soon
end
you'll need to add a couple of decision
statements to properly add branching
logic to the application to satisfy the
requirements
to create the initial code for this
challenge enter the following code
so let's do that
review the business rules for this
challenge
rule one
your code should only display one
message
the message that your code displays will
depend on the other five rules for rules
two to six the higher numbered rules
take precedence over the lower numbered
rules rule 2 if the user's subscription
will expire in 10 days or less display
the message your subscription will
expire soon renew now
rule three if they use a subscription
will expire in five days or less display
the messages your subscription expires
in underscore days
renew now and save 10 percent
note be sure to replace the underscore
character displayed in the message above
with the value stored in the variable
days until expiration when you construct
your message output
rule 4 if the use of subscription will
expire in one day display the messages
your subscription expires within a day
renew now and save 20 percent
rule five
if the user's subscription has expired
display the message your subscription
has expired
rule six if the user's subscription
doesn't expire in 10 days or less
display nothing
Implement Your solution using IF
statements Your solution must use
separate if and if else statements to
implement the business rules the if else
statement can include multiple else if
parts
create an if else statement that
displays a message about when the
subscription will expire tip
use and else if to ensure each
expiration rule is accounted for
create a separate if statement that
displays a discount offer the business
rules indicate when a discount should be
offered
we are using the built-in dot net random
class to return a random value between 1
and 12. the generated random value
denotes the number of days until a
subscription expires
based on the generated random value our
code makes a decision as it were using
IF else if conditional logic to Output
an appropriate message and if relevant
set the discount percentage variable
to an appropriate discount value note
that string interpolation is used here
to include the appropriate discount
percentage value within the outputted
message for string interpolation to work
a dollar symbol is included immediately
before the relevant string literal the
variable values contained within the
string literal and wrapped in curly
brackets these rules are followed to
implement string interpolation correctly
using the c-sharp language
so let's compare our code solution to
the one provided in the Microsoft
learned course material
so to do this let's press the continue
button
we can run our code by typing.net run in
the terminal window and pressing the
enter key
great
part 3 module three
at this point
I'm going to skip to part three add
logic to c-sharp console applications
get started with C sharp part three
module 3 Branch the flow of code using
the switch case construct in C sharp
and we're on unit 2 of this module a
switch statement is a c-sharp selection
statement that provides an alternative
to an if else if else else branching
construct the switch statement provides
advantages over and if else if else else
construct when evaluating a single value
against a list of known matching values
consider the following scenario you're
working on an application related to
food nutrition
a section of the code deals with fruits
your code includes a variable named
fruit that's used to hold the name of
the different types of fruit you have a
list of the 20 fruits that your
application is focused on
you want to Branch your code based on
the value assigned to fruit
in this scenario you can use a switch
statement to create a separate Branch
for each type of fruit further down the
page we are guided through a coding
exercise to help us understand switch
statements let's go through the
step-by-step instructions for this
coding exercise
ensure that you have Visual Studio code
open and program.cs displayed in the
editor panel type the following code
into the visual studio code editor so
let's do that
basically in this switch statement you
are evaluating the employee level
variables value in the case where the
employee level variable equals 100 the
title variable is set to Junior
associate in the case where the employee
level variable value is 200 the title
variable is set to a string value of
senior associate
in the case where the employee level
variable is set to 300 the title
variable is set to a value of manager if
the employee level variable value does
not match any of these cases the code
within the default section is run and
the title variable is set to associate
on the visual studio code file menu
select save
the program.cs file must be saved before
building or running the code
at the terminal command prompt type.net
run and then press enter
note if you see a message saying
couldn't find a project to run ensure
that the terminal command prompt
displays the expected test project
folder location
you should see the following output
take a minute to review the switch
statement that you entered notice that
the switch statement defines a single
code block that includes a list of
switch sections
to the right of the switch keyword is a
switch expression that's enclosed in
parentheses
notice the list of switch sections
inside the code block the switch code
block contains a list of switch sections
each of which includes one or more
switch labels
in addition each switch section includes
a statement list that will execute if
the label is equal to the switch
expression defined at the top of the
switch statement
the switch expression is evaluated
against the case labels from top to
bottom until a value that is equal to
the switch expression is found
if none of the labels are a match the
statement list for the default case will
be executed if no default is included
control is transferred to the end point
of the switch statement each label must
provide a value type
that matches the type specified in the
switch expression
note the optional default label can
appear at any position within the list
of switch sections however most
developers choose to put it last because
it makes more sense logically to
position default as the final option
regardless of the position the default
section will be evaluated last in our
example the switch expression is
employee level
each switch section has a single switch
label case or default
the matching switch section is defined
by case 200 since employee level equals
200.
notice that each switch section is
separated from the next only one switch
section is allowed to be executed this
means the execution of a switch section
is not permitted to fall through to the
next switch section the break keyword is
one of several ways to end a switch
section before it gets to the next
section
if you forget the break keyword or
optionally the return keyword the
compiler will generate an error
change the level variable value to see
how the switch statement evaluates it to
exercise the default case let's change
the employee's level by modifying the
value assignment
so if we assign the value 201 to the
employee level variable and we run the
code
now when we run the code you should see
the more generic title used
since the employee level doesn't match
any labels the default label is matched
modify a switch section to include
multiple labels
suppose our company decided to give all
level 100 employees the title senior
associate
the same title as level 200 employees as
the developer you decide to implement
this by removing the first switch
section belonging to label case 100
and instead allow both the case 100 and
case 200 labels to execute the same
switch section
save your code file and then use Visual
Studio code to run your code enter.net
run from the terminal command prompt to
run your code
both of the case labels 100 and 200 are
now paired with the switch section that
sets the title to the string value
senior associate
part 5 module 1 unit 6 guided project
so let's skip to part 5 create methods
in c-sharp console applications get
started with c-sharp part 5 module 1
write your first C sharp method the C
sharp programming language allows you to
create all sorts of robust applications
suppose you want to write to perform
operations on unpredictable user input
you may want to add logic to handle
incorrect input convert input into a
workable format and perform the correct
operation
as your applications grow larger in size
keeping track of your code can quickly
become a challenge methods also called
functions are a key part of keeping code
structured efficient and readable a
method is a modular unit of code and a
fundamental programming concept a method
is often designed to perform a specific
task and contains code to execute that
task
the name of a method should clearly
reflect its task which improves code
readability
learning how to use methods will help
you build feature-rich applications more
quickly
in this module you'll learn to create
your own methods to perform specific
tasks
you'll learn how methods can simplify
and shorten code
as well as keep things organized and
easy to find
so let's skip to unit 6. in unit 6 of
this module we are presented with a code
challenge where we learn among other
Concepts to reuse a method in code
exercise complete the challenge to
create a reusable method
code challenges reinforce what you've
learned and help you gain some
confidence before continuing on
the focus of this challenge is to modify
code so that it is reusable and can be
executed at any time
tell a fortune
you are helping to develop a massive
multiplayer role-playing game
each player has a luck stat that can
affect their odds of finding rare
treasure each day a player can speak to
an in-game fortune teller that reveals
whether their luck stat is high low or
neutral
the game currently has code to generate
a player's Fortune but it isn't reusable
your task is to create a tell Fortune
method that can be called at any time
and replace the existing logic with a
call to your method in this challenge
you're given some starting code
you must decide how to create and call
the toll Fortune method
then we are presented with the details
of how to create the code solution for
the relevant challenge here
to get started with this code challenge
we are instructed to copy this code and
paste the code into our program.cs file
codes challenge create a reusable method
in the code that you started with
there's a generic text array followed by
good bad and neutral text arrays
depending on the value of luck one of
the arrays is selected and displayed
alongside the generic text your
challenge is to create a reusable method
that prints a player's Fortune at any
time
the method should contain the logic that
is already present in the code provided
update the code to use a method to
display the fortune
use what you've learned about creating
and calling methods to complete the
update
test your code by changing the value of
luck and calling the method again
verify that your code produces one of
the following messages
whether you get stuck and need to peek
at the solution or you finish
successfully continue on to view a
solution to this challenge let's press
the continue button to compare our code
with the solution in this challenge
provided on the Microsoft learn platform
excellent
so
in this code exercise we are instructed
to write code to call a block of code
once I.E the code we have wrapped if you
like in the tell Fortune method
then change the value of the luck
variable
and then call the relevant block of code
now wrapped in the toll Fortune method a
second time so by using a method to wrap
the relevant code block we can call this
code block twice simply by typing in the
method name followed by opening and
closing brackets and then a semicolon of
course twice in our code like this
through the use of a method not only
have we appropriately addressed the
requirement for this code challenge we
have created cleaner code
code that is easier to maintain and
easier to read
once we have written and run our code we
can then check the output of our
application against the expected output
provided by Microsoft learn to confirm
that we have implemented our code
correctly
we can also compare our code solution to
the one provided on the Microsoft learn
platform
in this code exercise we are applying a
lot of different C sharp concepts for
example along with appropriately
wrapping a block of code in a method so
that it becomes one unit of code if you
like this code includes randomization
functionality one-dimensional string
arrays conditional logic implemented
using a ternary operator and a nested
ternary operator for conditionally
setting the value of a variable a for
loop as well as string interpolation
so by going through all of the course
material you'll learn about foundational
c-sharp Concepts such as these and much
more
so now I have completed all six parts of
the course material and I've just
qualified to take the certification exam
so this is me actually taking the exam
[Music]
foreign
wrong after telling you at the beginning
of this video that I have over 20 years
of experience it's all a bit
embarrassing
that I actually got one of the questions
wrong
okay
it just goes to show
even experienced c-sharp developers
should periodically refresh their
knowledge of the foundational c-sharp
Concepts
oh well I did pass the certification
exam so I can now claim my certificate
excellent
so once you have completed this
certification you can further your
education in c-sharpon.net by going
through the great content at these urls
I cannot stress enough how valuable this
certification is I really wish I'd had
resources and free certifications like
this available to me when I was first
getting started on my journey as a
developer
as an experienced c-sharp and net
developer I highly recommend going
through the process of earning your
foundational c-sharp with Microsoft
developer certificate you can do it
thank you and take care